But I really wish I had my hammer
Hammer? Quite unique, was made from this
this special metal from the heart of a dying star
And when I spun it really really fast it gave me the ability to fly
You rode a hammer?
No, I didn't ride the hammer. The hammer ride you on your back?
No, no I used to spin. It really fast, and if it would pull me off th-
Oh my God
The hammer pulled you off?!?
The ground! Pulled me off the ground!
Up into the air and I would fly.
Every time I through it, it would always
Came back to me
sounds like you had a pretty special and intimate relationship with this hammer and that losing that was almost
Comparable to losing a loved one
It's a nice way of putting it
That is Chris Hemsworth on Thor Ragnarok and that character
Well you go ahead, yeah
That's our director Taika Waititi
Playing that character and that stemmed from we're on set playing around with the weapons
before we shot the scene that was one line originally and
The art department just went mental on their you know
Artistic collaboration and in range of all sorts of ridiculous weapons and we were laughing about oh my god
What the hell is this thing and what the hell is that?
Hey, hey we know each other, he's a friend from work!
Chanting: Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk
Where have you been?
Everybody thought you were dead there's so much has happened since I last saw you
I Lost my hammer.
like yesterday, so that's still pretty fresh
Loki
Lo-Loki's alive can you believe it
He's up there
Loki! Look who it is
*Hulk Smash*
Hey Everybody that quarry clip is sooo perfect
They completely nailed that improve scene and they actually did say that they improved a lot of that
So I'll explain the war-bound, in the context of the movie and the differences from the comics
It's a little bit different, but they do have a lot of Easter eggs and no matter how many times
I think about it, that Loki clip is still funny. Loki look who it is! Thor actually had no idea that that happened
He didn't watch that it Hulk probably didn't tell him after oh yeah
I thrashed your brother pretty good, banner tends to not remember everything super clearly when he's Hulk
But if you didn't know, there's a new round of that Thor ticket giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
Leave a comment on the video announce a new winner at the end of this
But the whole thing about the warbound in the movie is that this isn't a Planet Hulk movie even though
There's a lot of Planet Hulk in here so the only real warbound characters that they included from the comics are Korg and meek
It obviously meek doesn't show up in this
It's just Thor trying to explain this hammer, and they've been saying a lot about the actual tone of the movie
And how they try to play it a little bit lighter with the more ridiculous big Ragnarok things
So it's a nice balance a big WTF, but also not taking it too Seriously
This is the example of them not taking themselves too seriously
Thor does have a very special relationship with this hammer even Odin had trouble taming it so it was like he was
Destined to become worthy and pick it up like he didn't choose the hammer as a child the hammer chose him once he became worthy
enough, so
There's like a whole lifetime of adventures that we haven't seen Thor have before we see him in the first Thor movie
within seconds Hella
smashes that in the film and though there's some questions about how she's able to do that because she's either worthy or
Two- she's just strong enough to break Odin's enchantment
And I think it's just number two they just want to show you how powerful she is
But Korg just completely takes the gas out of it when Thor tries to explain what his hammer does ahem uh? No
I didn't ride down the hammer. The hammer ride you on your back?
No, no I spin. It really fast, and it would pull me off th-
Oh My God, the hammer pulled you off??
And then he just completely
deconstructs Thor's relationship with the hammer in seconds this crazy gladiator that you wouldn't think would be so
Philosophical turns out to be one of the deepest characters in this fighting pit, so this is hole implied backstory for Cork
And they actually do get into it a little bit in the comics
But Tyga steals all the scenes that he's in in this movie
So there is some cool warbound stuff
But it's not straight-up
Planet Hulk like you would read in the comics the way they talk about the hammer though like losing a loved one
Remember this is also Ragnarok
So I think is just teeing up the idea that some really big characters might wind up dying in this film albeit
Not the a-list characters that are part of the Avengers movies, so
Odin is on the chopping block although you do wonder who's going to be king if Thor's not going to be king after
Infinity war although that's kind of what I'm hoping for him if this doesn't even get into any of the Hulk stuff that they announced
So if you don't know they just had the premiere of birth or in Kevin Feige and Mark Ruffalo teased a whole trilogy
Within the next three films so part 1 of this three-part Hulk story is Thor Ragnarok
Part 2 and part 3 are gonna be both of those next Avengers films so obviously
There's been a lot said about why they can never make a Hulk film because of the whole rights situation with Universal
And how that's just a giant headache
So instead of doing that they're making a stealth Hulk film inside of these other films
Which I think is a pretty clever thing to do
But a lot of you picked up on the idea of where Hulk is in this movie
so he's kind of doing the Thor thing where you shirk your
responsibilities you just give in to your baser instincts it's much easier to
Surrender to the big ring guy rather than try and fight him all the time
So that's what he's been doing for the past couple of years
He hasn't been banner since the end of Avengers age of Ultron so it's almost like banner when?
Vacation and let Holt take the driver's seat, and he's been having so much fun
So there's a lot of fun in here, too
so I think the whole idea is that he's getting that out of his system like Thor is slowly becoming more king like and
Responsible banner is getting more responsible
He'll find that balance between
Green guy and banner by the end of Avengers 4 so we can start speculating on future Hulk stuff after Avengers 4
But I would love to see more Hulk in space movies if they do a lot of the cosmic movies the James Gunn has been
Teasing out the non guardians of the galaxy space movies with different characters
I think Hulk and Thor would be perfect for that they don't necessarily have to show up in the same movie though
But a lot of you did ask though. There was this funny story about Mark Ruffalo accidentally
live-streaming part of the Thor Ragnarok movie premiere that wasn't quite as big a deal as people made it out to be he
accidentally left his
Instagram a livestream app open on his phone stuck it in his pocket so last night
If people were still watching his stream
They were getting a lot of black
Footage from the inside of his pocket with the audio from the first 15 minutes or so of the film maybe not quite that much
But the feed cut out eventually and then they deleted the video
Like he's the coolest dude ever so probably somebody from Marvel realized
What was going on and it's like can you please delete this this is turning into a big thing?
But there's a whole team of people from Marvel that handle the actors and help them with that kind of stuff
So usually when situations like that develop somebody jumps on it pretty quick
But a lot of you been asking me when I'm gonna post my review video the embargo is up next week
So I'll be able to post my non-spoilery review
I think it's on Thursday, but I'll remind people there'll be more Thor Ragnarok videos, but it's a great film
It's very different from the previous Thor films, so I think I've talked a little bit about that
I'll try to explain when I post my review video
They do a really good job of balancing heart humor and spectacle because that's really what you do with Thor movies
You need some of those big spectacles
But a lot of it is so ridiculous that you have to take it not so seriously like this clip here
So let me know in the comments what you guys do have a chance to see it what you think of it so far
So some of you internationally will get to see it a little bit before other
So please don't post spoilers if you are seeing it before other people there's a whole bunch of comic book premieres this week
So I'll try to get through those videos as fast as possible
But I have a new game of Thrones new Star Wars the last Jedi and a bunch of other stuff
So I'll try to get to that as fast as possible
Congratulations to the latest giveaway winner shale
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
You can click here for more Thor Ragnarok and infinity war and you can click here for all my flash videos from episode 1 last
Night, thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight